[موسيقى]
تخيل عالماً كنت نجم
فيلمك الخاص ، وهذا ما تعد به شركة واحدة.
باستخدام VR الذي يعد حقًا
ثوريًا تمامًا ، يمكننا أن نأخذ
جسمك بالكامل ونحولك في الواقع
إلى صورة رمزية ونضعك
في عالم رقمي غني بالتفاصيل حيث
تصبح نوعًا ما نجم
ضيوف الفيلم الذين يرتدون ملابس من الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين  معدات الواقع الافتراضي
وتدخل الغرفة التي يشاهدونها بينما
تتحول أجسادهم إلى صور رمزية رقمية في
العالم الافتراضي ، يجب أن يعملوا
معًا من خلال التفاعل مع
محيطهم إذا كانوا يريدون الوصول إلى
النهاية ، فنحن نصنع تجارب تدمج
القيمة العاطفية أو التأثير العاطفي
الذي تحصل عليه من  فيلم هوليوود جيد
مع الإثارة العميقة التي تحصل عليها من
حديقة الملاهي والتر باركس هو
رئيس مجلس الإدارة والمؤسس المشارك لشركة Dreamscape
Immersive المعروفة بإنتاج
هوليوو  الأفلام الرائجة مثل
رجال المصارعين باللون الأسود وتقرير ماينوريتي ، إنه
يجلب قائمة طويلة من كبار المستثمرين
إلى الشركة الناشئة التي تدعمها بعض
الأسماء الأكثر شهرة في صناعة السينما
بما في ذلك وارنر ميديا ، ال
ركة الأم لشبكة سي إن إن وكذلك ستيفن سب
لبرغ وزيمر  افتتح 21st Century Fox
AMC Theaters MGM و IMAX على سبيل المثال لا الحصر
موقعه الدولي الأول الخميس
إنتربرايز
مول الإمارات ، يراهن فريق مجيد ألفا المطور للمراكز التجارية
على تقنية Dreamscapes
لقيادة كرة القدم ، سيكون مستقبل
الأسطورة أكثر وأكثر
يتغذى الإنسان والكثافة البشرية ،
يتعلق الأمر بقدرتنا على
تزويد عملائنا فعليًا
بفرصة خلق لحظات رائعة
وكلها تتعلق بالتفاعل
البشري والعواطف ، و Dreamscape هو
بطل في ذلك في الماضي كان
الواقع الافتراضي مخصصًا على نطاق واسع
للألعاب و  الممارسات التجارية
Dreamscape تأمل أن
تعيد منصتها تعريف الترفيه على ما أعتقد  في
بداية ما يمكن أن يكون عليه هذا ، ولكن أيضًا
يجب أن يستمر المنحنى التكنولوجي
في التحرك بحيث يكون أرخص ،
ويمكن الوصول إليه ، وأقل حجمًا ،
وستكون مدة عشر سنوات مثيرة ، سأخبرك
أن الكثير من
سيباستيان سي إن إن
[موسيقى]